welcome to this video you let's say
modern 33 okay it's not playing the
modern though would be g6 or d6 ok and
nums oh yeah there was also modern at
one time nowadays it's the most usual
opening that you can think of ok i play
the classical the same ish is alright
but it is so risky here always with this
bad pawn structure um ok Knight f3 or a
3 I think a three it's both both
possible you can also go Knight f3 first
ok you have this is a very classical way
to play this plug and play Knight deform
trading off even a bit more ok seems he
does not want to do that the thing is
that knight on c6 is something not
particularly well placed you sometimes
rather wanted on a 6 or d 7 depending on
them on the particular pawn structure
yeah I can consider before in this
position or III it's both possible ok
let's try them with more aggressive
approach with e 4 and then the ND five
now Emma sisson remove is 94 actually ok
let's pretend
let's develop develop first now I
originally wanted to go e5 but 94 is a
bit a bit annoying maybe okay maybe I
could have taken 20 form Y are not easy
not easy okay so he wants to to trade
the bishops and then being able to play
night to to f4 okay not much I could do
about that yeah that looks okay for
black yeah I normally when I play this
it's not I don't play the classical
system that often when I'm when I do
play it I normally played with III but I
wanted to try something else yeah the
idea of this maneuver was to ask black
what the night is doing here yeah what
do I do now I can move this night away
but it doesn't really do much on a
one-armed on any other square Knight d4
he will take yeah let's let's that's
complete centralization here you
probably will retreat the night from f6
anyway to have six anyway I don't need
to do anything about it I mean it's not
doing doing much on age five yes move
the rock away from the f file yep here
we go f5 would have been an idea in some
positions but oh that's interesting now
that's it's always a debatable debatable
situation here with this capture only
five but I think here this is a position
where I should be quite comfortable
he's got this this whole onda form that
you can try to exploit but I have pretty
decent a pretty decent set up to make
sure that his control over the squares
not getting getting too annoying for
example the knight on f6 is very far
away from reaching the d4 square this
position would be a lot different if his
night would be on c6 arm could go there
quickly it doesn't seem to be the case
here now what would I want in this
position is if possible a minor piece
endgame where I'm able to get a person
on the queenside he sometimes manages to
move the night play at 50 k is taking
quite a lot of time now which surprises
me I mean this is not a super
complicated position
hmm she disconnected or something I mean
okay maybe he's one of those guys like
me sometimes taking those deep things
okay so he basically didn't know if he
should trade everything off or not yeah
understandable um came yeah I probably
can take and should take what now Queen
to d3 he can go quindi for a bit of an
annoying move that I cannot do without
that 24 is not possible now can take and
play Knight be five winning upon yeah
[ __ ] d 4 and a 7 my next move is
probably before between d3 this kind of
thing k allows me to play c5 harm
interesting
what if I've quindi form that actually
might be possible okay let's start with
before that's a move that has to be
played anyway getting control over see
50 so what tomorrow this is surprising
so c5 Gras our third no no no why this
white is better him just a matter of how
much how much better wide is this also
night a form which is interesting and
then c5 maybe this is this is even more
problematic not not quite sure c5 also
was good but not so easy to decide
isn't this what I don't get it I don't
get it if i take that is giving me the
check here right and i can probably just
do that I don't don't really think it's
enough but what is this I mean isn't
this time morning this is falling right
away now and beehive i also have Quincy
five check I mean you cannot even play
Bishop c 6 i'm just playing Quincy five
so I've to hit him to see six or what is
the cleanest way I should very
definitely speed up a bit this would
help
so here to to move the pawns finally not
sure if this is the best way technically
but ok ok nitey 30 given the pawns are
225 advanced really arm if I'm going be
six say there's still the B porn I mean
I didn't even think about that one how
stupid is that ok but I can play b7
right and I'm promoting yeah it was too
much Jack I overlooked that idea I can
take care of her I'm really just
promoting him check check
I have to pre move stuff checkmate okay
yeah what what happened in this game I
mean it wasn't much happening and this
is this is certainly a position that
should be about equal yeah he however he
gave up on the idea to do something with
have 5 i'm not sure of I mean this is
sometimes is an idea can you do that
this kind of thing yeah if I take with
rook yes this one I this is an
interesting way to play Adam it really
tries to make use of those two pieces
and there's also this idea
now there are there are some interesting
active ideas for black here that are not
clear to me at all but he okay decided
to play it in in a bit more conservative
way and now 95 I'm not really sure about
it this is a well-known structure but
then I don't think this this is so great
for black I mean the thing is he
basically gives me this majority that
very often will lead to a pass on the
queenside and the question really is but
where's the compensation normally it is
the the compensation is play on the dark
squares but I don't see this happening
so much I mean he is solid but I don't
see how many great compensation for him
what I find really amusing is that
stockfish things that like is minimally
better this is this is quite weird
because I mean why does never ever ever
ever losing yeah don't really see that
happening the computer I mean okay I
think that probably this is giving me
something yeah the computer agrees after
that white is slightly better but what
the computer wants to do this and then
click Queen d4 ok it says minus 007 so
about equal but well okay black can can
never you ever be better here okay it is
just if it's something it is it is equal
yeah it's here what be five losers I
think he should she should do that he
should do that move and then I want I
want him to go see five and I thought
that he I should be slightly better
after be 5i me taking taking is really
bad yeah this is very nice for what note
that this Bishop is a very stupid piece
yeah this is one point that is always a
problem whenever I'm building up this e
4 3 formation against the bishop however
you can do that then I'm dropping back
and now he can
sorry for painting it wrong Knight to c6
and possibly something to deform and
this is maybe a bit this is better for
white because of the passer on c5 but it
is not nothing very very special or so
so this is what you should do this this
is a thing just losing 93 and now it's
it's over you cannot cover the pawn this
is directly giving up basically well
here maybe I can also take so I have the
check or i can take here I mean he
really only has just one check one check
and that's it yeah Queen d4k this is 0
this is a winning end game which I
probably didn't play the best but it was
them too much I think okay well thanks
for watching